Democrats are also asking questions
about the sudden departure of the FBI's
deputy director Andrew McCabe also a
former acting director stepped down
yesterday just weeks before his
scheduled retirement FBI sources tell
CBS News it was McCabe's decision while
a Justice Department source indicates he
was told to leave Jeff Bezos outside FBI
headquarters in Washington with more on
this story Jeff good morning good
morning for more than eight months the
FBI's number two has been the target of
increasing criticism not only for his
role in the Russia investigation but
also his role overseeing the Clinton
private email server investigation but
sources say within the last few day
something changed inside the FBI that
led to Andrew McCabe's abrupt departure
I worked very very closely with director
Comey deputy director Andrew McCabe led
the FBI's Russia investigation when it
began in 2016 and became the acting
director of the bureau when President
Trump hired James Comey director Comey
enjoyed broad support within the FBI but
over the last several months mccabe has
become a lightning rod for critics
Republicans on Capitol Hill and
President Trump have singled McCabe out
after it was revealed his wife received
almost $700,000 from Democratic Party
sources in her unsuccessful bid for the
Virginia State Senate well we came got
more than five hundred thousand dollars
from essentially Hillary Clinton and is
he investigating Hillary Clinton's sir
McCabe led the FBI's investigation into
Hillary Clinton's emails and his role in
the probe is under review by the DOJ
Inspector General president Trump has
denied reports that he asked McCabe who
he voted for when McCabe became acting
FBI director the president has been
openly critical of the deputy director
on Twitter McCabe is racing the clock to
retire with full benefits on Monday in
an email to the FBI workforce director
Christopher Ray mentioned the inspector
general investigation saying that he
would hold
people accountable and that mccabe plans
to take leave until his official
retirement on march 18th
and so mccabe is leaving early and he
has been relieved of his duties the
White House said the president had
nothing to do with it but that President
Trump stands by his criticism of McCabe
and his wife John alright Jeff the gays
thanks so much